[Musik]
gotthard heißt die schweiz in ihrem
innersten die kampfbereitschaft an
diesem berg war schon immer ausgeprägt
nun gilt sie da 23 kilometer langen pass
straße die jeden frühling an heute aus
den schmier gepreist und gehauen werden
muss dieses jahr war die arbeit der
schneeräumer besonders mühevoll und
gefährlich denn der winter wollte nicht
weichen
[Musik]
es ist der 24
april und auch im urnerischen hosten
thale auf 1500 meter über meer
am fuß des gotthard pass es gelegen wird
es allmählich zeit für den frühling
in vier wochen soll die barriere
geöffnet werden
dann wird es hier mit der ruhe vorbei
sein dann wird es für fußgänger auf der
badstraße keinen platz mehr haben
die pasok öffnung das ist seine aufgabe
werner kloos der gotthard straßenmeister
und seine männer arbeiten unter
schwierigen bedingungen
die lawinen reste überall am straßenrand
zeigen es
dagegen konnten zwei teams kämpfen sich
durch den schnee der passhöhe entgegen
eines von norden her
dieses hier ist auf der südseite amberg
eine arbeit am gleichen berg doch oft
unter äußerst unterschiedlichen
wetterverhältnissen sonne auf der
nordseite nebel hier im süden so ist der
gott hat eben ein berg der
unwägbarkeiten
[Musik]
also für mich ist schlimmste war vor
sieben tagen haben die männer unten in
erholung und hospental angefangen noch
fast vier wochen haben sie zeit die
passstrasse zu räumen und für den
verkehr instand zu stellen
genügend zeit so scheint es da kann auch
der neuschnee der letzten tage keine
unruhe verursachen
[Musik]
aufgeregt ist hier oben einzig dieses
murmeltier nach dem durchgang der fräser
findet es seine höhle nicht mehr das
tier hätte wohl besser noch etwas länger
geschlafen
auf der nordseite ist louis baumann
unterwegs der chef der unterhalten
er ist zuständig für den autotunnel und
die passstrasse die fahrt geht entlang
zahlreicher frischer lawinen hier auf
der nordseite sind die fräsen bereits
bis weit in die höhe vorangekommen
wo und wann es dem erschienen wagen
können in den tiefschnee vorzudringen
das muss pro sie müller entscheiden er
der verantwortliche für die sicherheit
auf dieser seite des passes kommt eben
von einer kündigung der lage zurück
er berichtet baumann über die
lawinensituation tresen und die firma
zum trainer
dennoch muss man aufpassen dass du hast
mir gekommen
[Musik]
es ist kurz vor sieben uhr morgens im
werk ohhh von airolo trifft
straßenmeister werner kloos seine
mitarbeiter den brauch mit schnupftabak
anzustoßen hatte von der anderen seite
des gotthards ins tessin gebrannt durch
euro fährt werner kloos bergwärts seine
männer sind in den letzten tagen gut
vorwärts gekommen
es sieht so aus als ob der zeitplan bis
zur eröffnung am 23 mai eingehalten
werden können
hans peter wyrsch macht seine rolle bei
600 bereit ein kraftvolles gefährt
hergestellt im emmental kopiert auch
schon in china schafft bis 2.600 tonnen
schnee in der stadt
das hat natürlich seinen preis gegen 400
tausend franken kostet die potente
schneeschleuder
[Applaus]
einen kilometer weiter oben verschwindet
die straße in schnee es ist eine
schlüsselstelle bei der schneeräumung
auf der südseite
hinter einer schneewand versteckt liegt
das portal des tunnels voraus rollt wie
stets das raupenfahrzeug bereits 30
jahre alt günstig übernommen von der
schweizer armee
doch noch immer dicht es den schnee auch
in steilsten laden gelegentlich klopft
und knallt es vielleicht ein stein dann
müssen die rotoren neu fixiert werden
und dann ist viel handarbeit angesagt
kam an gott hat
doch mit der öffnung des tunnels portals
wird auch der druck auf den straßen
meister steigen wenn es dauernd
unterwegs am berg denn gleich mehrere
baustellen sind zu koordinieren dabei
bewegt er sich durch lawinen land was
meint seine frau dazu dass er jeden
morgen aufbricht zu dieser nicht ganz
ungefährlichen arbeit das er letztes
jahr am gotthard selbst in eine lawine
geraten ist darüber möchte er jetzt
gerade nicht sprechen
werner kloos will wissen wie es oberhalb
des tunnels auf dem letzten kilometer
vor der passhöhe aussieht doch dann
endet die fahrt ohne freese gibt es hier
kein weiterkommen
die schneemenge im tunnel gibt eine
ahnung davon mit welcher kraft hier
zuweilen der wind bläst die temperaturen
sind gestiegen nassschnee rutsche auch
in die straße hinein zeigen dass es nun
gefährlich wird am berg für heute ist
der rückzug vom gotthard angezeigt
frühmorgens am zweiten mai nur noch
wenige hundert meter sind es bis zur
passhöhe
in kürze werden die männer mit ihren
kollegen zusammentreffen
die vom norden her kommen die maschinen
werden startklar gemacht
auf der passhöhe liegt der schnee fast
haushoch doch wenn die fräse mal den
asphalt freigelegt hat schmilzt der
restliche schnee schnell die weißen
wände strahlen in fetten bands die
meisten ist schon kräftig die arbeit im
cockpit ist anstrengend denn die
schweren maschinen müssen
zentimetergenau geführt werden
ansonsten drohen teure kollision mit dem
felsen oder mit bauteilen an straßen
rannten dann geraten die fräsen von der
nordseite in sicht die schneeräumer sind
oben angekommen
schon sprechen einige im unterland davon
den pass früher bereits vor pfingsten zu
öffnen
doch die folgenden tage werden einen
anderen plan diktieren überhaupt bis zur
öffnung sind noch zahlreiche arbeiten zu
erledigen damit dieser bergstrecke auch
von flachland automobilisten mit ihren
sommerreifen befahren werden kann
so müssen sie den kilometer leitplanken
die wegen der winterlichen lawinen
entfernt worden sind wieder montiert
werden
oben auf dem berg macht sich werner
kloos auf in den tiefen schnee vor und
rückwärts und wieder seitlich der
straßenmeister wirkt wie ein verwirrter
schneeschuhwanderer er sucht nach dem
unsichtbaren straßenrand der hospiz
ausfahrten eine antenne im rucksack
das gps in der hand so lassen sich die
fixpunkte präzise finden und mit einer
farbmarkierung für die fräsen sichtbar
machen
im tunnel untergebracht ist auch ein
aufenthaltsraum für die straßenarbeiter
es ist mittagszeit und wollte an diesem
besonderen tag der pass ankunft kocht
der chef eine form der wertschätzung für
seine mitarbeiter
der gotthard 2091 meter über meer und
noch viel mächtiger als mythischer kraft
[Musik]
an diesem tag ist er ein ort zum feiern
es ist diese stelle unweit der passhöhe
wo werner kloos vor einem jahr in eine
lawine geraten ist sagen die körper der
beiden box ja und ich habe vor das ist
aus abgelöst
der göttliche kriterien des schwer
brauchst du hast einfach zurückzieht
oder die ganze straße
leute die musik muss aber das ist ein
ganz mieser trick kann zwar nicht
einfach darüber die fans bald danach
kommt weiß nicht was das dauert ja
historisch weiß man was los ist und die
indische lehre sehr nah da sind wir
haben wird sich der jetzt verdanken
haben wir das gleiche aber es dass wir
dann den kritischen aber bewusst dass
eigentlich passiert ist das ist schon
hinter sich ist ja das hat man
eigentlich gesagt das ist eigentlich
wirklich sagen ja das ist eine lawine
hab ich natürlich mausetot
das ist eigentlich der unterschied von
denen acht erstmals das trikot
das gotthard mattli auf halbem weg
zwischen hospental und dem hospiz
gelegen
in diesem haus kam vor 68 jahren hans
egli von allen mattli hause genannt zur
welt den winter verbringt er unten in
horsten teil
doch bereits lange vor der pass ordnung
und dem ersten verkehr kommt er nach
oben vor ostern ist hans regel hier
einem einsamen wanderer auf dessen weg
in den süden begegnet
heute sind die schneeräumer in scott hat
mattli zum mittagessen eingekehrt hause
schwiegertochter kocht für die männer
es ist vier tage vor pfingsten und im
unterland spricht man schon davon den
pass bereits dann zu öffnen
der wird vom buttert hospiz möchte wegen
der planung gewissheit haben doch werner
kloos kann diese nicht bieten
überhaupt ist der angesichts der
wetterprognosen sehr skeptisch dass
diese vorgezogene pass öffnung klappt es
ist ja nicht nur der schnee der weg
geräumt werden muss es sind nicht nur
die lawinen die aus den hängen drohen in
den arenberg flanken liegen ende winter
lose felsbrocken die auf die straße
stürzen könnten
fels räumung heißt dieser notwendige
teil des kampfes an bord hat
freitag vor pfingsten von der idee den
pass an diesem wochenende zu öffnen ist
man abgekommen
zu eindeutig ist die wettersituation
werner kloos wer den berg hoch um zu
schauen ob bei diesem üblen wetter
überhaupt irgendwelche arbeiten an der
straße ausgeführt werden können
oberhalb des gotthard mattli liegt die
antwort auf der straße meterhoch
räumungsarbeiten ampass wären bei dieser
situation für die männer
lebensgefährlich
heute arbeiten die schneeräumer im
werkhof göschenen wo von allen seiten
das wasser ins enge tal stürzt
nur eine nacht später ein prachtvoller
frühlingstag erhält die innerschweiz der
föhn hat den himmel geputzt die
temperatur auf 20 grad hoch getrieben
und vor dem gotthardtunnel stauen sich
die autos an diesem pfingstsamstag auf
einer länge von 14 kilometern
dass werner klose an diesem 22 mai durch
den gotthardtunnel auf die südseite
fahren muss ist ein schlechtes zeichen
denn eigentlich müsste morgen der pass
auf gehen durch starke schneefälle
verunmöglichen eine fahrt über den berg
und dann geht es auch auf der südseite
nicht mehr weiter eine fräse band werner
kloos einen weg durch den neuschnee
dabei löst der weg geschleuderte schnee
unterhalb der straße immer wieder
kleinere lawinen aus es ist noch früh am
morgen
werner kloos folgt der fräser im
schritttempo
längst ist ihm klar geworden dass er
wegen der lawinengefahr heute keine
weiteren leute mehr auf der südseite
einsetzen kann
eine mächtige lawine liegt über der
passstrasse die zuvor bereits geräumt
war
auf einer breite von 300 metern muss die
fräse eine schlucht durch die
schneemassen schaffen
senkrecht über dem bedrettotal für
werner kloos besteht kein zweifel diese
passstraße kann morgen kaum geöffnet
werden
einen ganzen vormittag benötigt close
für die paar kilometer bis zur passhöhe
von der nordseite hier sind bereits die
verantwortlichen der hospiz betriebe
oben angelangt
sie möchten sich auf die angekündigte
morgige eröffnung vorbereiten
sie möchten wissen was ist aus dem
unterland sind die chefs auf den berg
gekommen
die beratung fällt kurz aus der
entscheid ist eindeutig diese straße
kann morgen den verkehr nicht geöffnet
werden
eine frage oder ganze gastronomie er von
der region im gotthard aufgrund von
politischen situation wo man darüber
natur vereint mit dem magischen zauber
vor ort ist
und auf der fahrt talwärts findet sich
gleich am straßenrand ein weiteres
eindrückliches argument gegen eine
öffnung eine woche später
heute ist es endlich soweit zwar
bedecken schneeverwehungen die
passstrasse doch werner kloos und seine
mitarbeiter haben ja noch vier stunden
die straße passierbar zu machen
bis um 11 uhr die barrieren weggeräumt
werden sollen
lacht nein freundlich ist dieser berg
nicht geworden
noch gestern gingen auf der südseite
zahlreiche lawinen nieder
vor der barriere oberhalb von airolo
stauen sich schon jene die den gotthard
als erste überqueren wollen
es ist jedes jahr ein kleines ritual von
kameras festgehalten wenn die barrieren
zur seite geräumt werden wenn der
gotthard dem winter entrissen wird
[Musik]
die luft null grad der wind stürmisch
die schneewände erdrückend hoch für die
reisenden aus dem tiefland muss die
schneewelt auf dem gotthard beklemmend
sein und fast will es scheinen als
gehörten die menschen nicht hierher
[Musik]